bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat il a donc reçu le feu
vert des commissions des finances de
l'assemblée nationale et du sénat pour
devenir le directeur général de la bpi
la banque publique d'investissement mais
pour nicolas dufour que 49 ans ancien
numéro 2 de capgemini le plus dur reste
à faire car la banque voulu par françois
hollande eux pour aider les entreprises
à traverser la crise en leur
garantissant des fonds propres reste en
plein chantier après huit mois de passes
d'armes entre l'elysée notamment et les
présidents de région nicolas dufourcq
aura comme un défi à relever bien
d'agréger à la fois oséo le fsi le fonds
stratégique d'investissement dont on
ignore encore la valeur mais aussi un
des secteurs une des branches de la cdc
la caisse des dépôts et consignations
qui est je vous le rappelle actionnaire
à 50 50 de la bpi avec l'état tout de
suite donc retour sur l'audition de
nicolas dufour par la commission des
finances du sénat bonne matinée à tous
alors monsieur le directeur
est-ce que je dois dire monsieur le
directeur général
non je dois dire monsieur sur un
inspecteur des finances monsieur le
préfigurateur et la commission des
finances du sénat vous entends en cette
fin de matinée et
dans le cadre de votre candidature au
poste de directeur général de bpi group
société créée par la loi du 31 décembre
et dès hier et vous le savez le
rapporteur général notre commission
françois marque a été le premier
signataire de la proposition de loi et
organiques et qui est nous conduit
précisément ce que le principal
dirigeant de la banque publique
d'investissement soit nommé après avis
public des commissions des finances des
deux assemblées et à l'issue de votre
audition nous serons amenés à voter et
je vous rappelle mes chers collègues
mais nous commençons être familier de
cette procédure qu'au terme de l'article
13 la constitution le président de la
république ne peut procéder à une
nomination
lorsque l'addition des votes négatifs
dans chaque commission représente au
moins trois cinquièmes des suffrages
exprimés au sein des commissions et on
vote à l'assemblée nationale on vote au
sénat
on ne publie que le scrutin ou
d'ensemble et une éventuelle majorité
négative des trois cinquièmes et est
calculé sur l'addition des votes
intervenus au sein de l'une et l'autre
des commissions des finances
c'est un exercice de consolidation et
monsieur le préfigurateur vous allez
devoir consolider
c'est ce qui me permet et de passer au
fond du sujet après avoir rappelé mais
nos collègues savent qu'il n'ya pas de
délégation de vote pour un tel scrutin
le caractère personnel cette audition et
conformément à la loi du 23 juillet 2010
une audition publique est ouverte à la
presse retransmise en direct sur le site
internet du sénat monsieur dufour et
vous allez nous dire en quelques mots
qui vous êtes rappeler votre parcours et
surtout vous nous présenter votre projet
stratégique et comment comptez vous
mettre sur de bons rails
ce nouvel établissement comment faire de
plusieurs pièces dont chacune a son
existence et sa culture est un
établissement intégrer un vrai groupe
tournait autour de ces différentes
vocations juxtaposition ou union comment
passer à quel rythme de la juxtaposition
à l'union
et s'agissant des structures de ce
groupe
il a été rappelé au cours du débat
parlementaire et que vous aviez un
moment donné exprimé une préférence
technique pour un schéma dans lequel la
société active en matière de crédit
aurait été la société de tête se ce
cette préoccupation a été assez
largement développé contredite
au cours du débat parlementaire il
serait donc utile que vous nous
dizier quel est aujourd'hui votre
analyse l'organisation que nous avons
voté et ethel optimale assure-t-elle en
particulier je terminerai par là à des
pays les meilleures conditions d'emprunt
ou en tout cas des conditions égales à
celles qui étaient obtenus par oseo
je m'arrête là monsieur le préfet
curateur et donc vous prie de bien
vouloir introduire notre débat par voie
par votre brève présentation et par
votre réponse à ses premières questions
ensuite rapporteur général et membre de
la commission vous poseront leurs
propres questions merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs se le rapporteur général
je me présente donc nicolas dufour que
j'ai 49 ans et je suis depuis 20 ans
dans un métier de chef d'entreprise
puisque je suis rentré chez france
télécom en 1993 j'ai passé une dizaine
d'années chez france télécom et une
dizaine d'années chez capgemini france
télécoms j'y suis rentré pour créer la
division multimédia de france télécom
qui regroupait les annuaires le minitel
la télévision par câble la télévision
par satellite est quelque chose que
j'avais découvert aux états unis qui est
l internet que nous avons lancé sous la
marque wanadoo j'ai donc ensuite
transformé cette division multimédia en
une société qui s'est appelée wanadoo
que j'ai côté le 18 juillet 2000 pour 20
milliards d'euros
et qui a ensuite connu une expansion
internationale importante ça a été ma
vie de 2,93 à 2003 j'ai quitté français
et comme en 2003 pour rejoindre
capgemini et partir sur une autre
aventure entrepreneuriale formidable
puisque la société s'est développée de
58 salariés à l'époque à 135 mille
salariés aujourd'hui pour une très
grande partie en europe aux états unis
et dans les marchés émergents en inde et
au brésil
et j'étais président général de wanadoo
numéro deux de france télécom et j'ai
été numéro de capgemini pendant donc une
une dizaine d'années j'ai accepté la
mission qu'on m'a proposé le 17 octobre
de préfigurer la banque d'investissement
mais si si ma candidature est acceptée
par les chambres de prendre la direction
générale de la banque publique
d'investissement pourquoi parce que
c'est aussi un projet entrepreneurial
formidable il s'agit de rassembler trois
entités qui sont toutes les trois de
très grande qualité aux héros fsi et
c'est les entrées cdc entreprises sont
trois entreprises bien gérées avec avec
des professionnels de l'investissement
ou de la banque qui sont de très grande
qualité on a une chance incroyable
les rassembler est un projet de
construction d'entreprises c'est ce que
j'aime faire
c'est ce que j'ai fait en fait depuis 20
ans et je pense que c'est ce que au fond
c'est mon métier
alors quand on fait pendant ces quelques
mois de préfiguration et où en est-on
aujourd'hui
où va-t-on je vais rapidement développer
ce point et le 17 octobre nous avions
quelque chose comme un embryon un
embryon de pacte d'actionnaires entre
l'état et la caisse des dépôts et
consignations ainsi qu'un projet de loi
relativement bref
et tout ceci j'allais dire ne faisait
par entreprise
c'est à dire c'était une construction
qui était tout de même un petit peu
administratives et qu'il a fallu
incorporé pour en faire une entreprise
bon je passe sur les intermédiaires de
calcul et mais enfin tout le travail qui
a été fait en novembre en décembre et
depuis le début de l'année est un
travail consistant à vous proposer une
structure qui est une pure structure
d'entreprise et qui donc respectera ce
qui a été la condition du succès aussi
bien du fsi que de cdc entreprises
depuis 15 ans et que oseo depuis tant
d'années puisque l'histoire de réaux
remonte loin comme vous le savez
conditions du soutien qu'ils aient
méthode privé missions d'intérêt général
le meilleur du privé le meilleur du
public
voilà donc cette banque publique
d'investissement nous la construisons de
manière à ce qu'elle soit gérée
opéré de la manière la plus
contemporaine qu'ils soient dans le
monde de l'entreprise
elle aura deux filiales une filiale
bancaire est une filiale fonds propres
dans la filiale fonds propres on va
procéder à la fusion de l'ensemble des
entités et parce qu'ils composent le
périmètre d'aujourd'hui c'est à dire
c'est les entreprises le fsi ainsi que
potentiellement quelques autres sociétés
de gestion apporté par la caisse des
dépôts et consignations l'innovation
capitale en particulier ou ou d'autres
de manière à avoir un grand ensemble
fonds propres une seule société autant
que possible est organisée de manière
fluide entre toutes les entités sachant
qu'aujourd'hui ce sont des équipes qui
se sont plutôt traditionnellement
regarder en chiens de faïence qu'autre
chose à ce sont des équipes qui sont et
qui ont été peu mélangés et plus tôt
parfois même opposé donc doublé
rassemblons et nous créons une grande
entité et de gestion des apports en
fonds propre public
du côté de la banque c'est la banque
oseo au capital de laquelle n'avons pu
d'investissement aura 90 % puisque oseo
gardera ses actionnaires minoritaires
qui sont les banques mutualistes et
privés ainsi que quelques petites
actions et méritas de type agence
française du développement et est même
l'ayant le conseil régional de bretagne
qui pour des raisons historiques à 0,1
pour cent du capital de zéro ça c'est la
structure légale de la bpi maintenant la
structure opérationnelle et managériale
dans la logique de ce que j'indique
c'est à dire une entreprise normale qui
est dirigé par un directeur général avec
un comité de direction
eh bien mon comité de direction sera
composé des patrons des six métiers de
la banque et les six métiers sont la
garantie
le financement l'innovation 30 direction
de l'innovation à la bpi leaf les fonds
de fonds donc l'investissement dans les
fonds privés
les fonds directs pme et les fonds
directs grandes entreprises
ça fait six métiers on rajoute un
directeur financier et que je nommerais
dès que je serai moi même confirmé que
me comme directeur général
un diacre la publication d'une stratégie
un inspecteur général pour le contrôle
des risques enfin tout ce qu'il touche
tout ce qui est normatif dans
l'organisation d'une banque
nous sommes très proches d'aboutir dans
cette dans cette structuration là de
sorte que si si ma candidature est
acceptée je pense que nous pouvons
accélérer la mise en place de l'an sont
des actions de la bpi l'avait pays ne
sera légalement où j'allais dire
contractuellement définitivement
opérationnel est incorporé que quand
l'opération fusions acquisitions sera
faite et elle sera faite seulement en
mai
puisque il faut attendre la clôture des
comptes de la caisse des dépôts et
consignations ainsi que d'oseo clôture
des comptes qui interviendra au mois
d'avril
parallèlement nous avons un dialogue
avec la commission européenne pour
obtenir les accords de la commission au
titre des aides d'état la commission
fait très attention à ce que la
construction la bpi ne soit pas une
occasion pour la puissance publique
française de réinjecter les dispositifs
d'être d'état qui n'auraient pas été
validés dont le dialogue questions
réponses a commencé avec la commission
européenne la commission ne demande pas
à ce stade de notifier ce qui est plutôt
une bonne nouvelle
une procédure beaucoup plus lourde
questions réponses donc normalement nous
devrions être estampillé fusions
acquisitions et bruxelles en mai en mai
nous aurons également
obtenu l'accord de l'autorité de
concurrence française puisqu'une
concentration que pour le disait le
président et puis nous aurons également
informé les représentants du personnel
etc
donc il ya beaucoup de choses à faire
pour que la bpi soit complètement
construite en revanche on peut dire que
la traduction opérationnelle de la bpi
commence d'ores et déjà à la limite même
indépendamment de ma personne puisque
les trois entités font bpi et se
projette déjà rebondi oseo a lancé dès
le 3 janvier une facilité de trésorerie
de 500 millions d'euros pour les pme
avec avec une dotation budgétaire pour
la financer la bonifier de 50 millions
d'euros ceci est disponible c'était une
mesure importante du pacte de
compétitivité depuis 3 janvier c'est un
produit de la gamme de produits de oséo
qui deviendra bpi financement il faut
d'ailleurs que ça se sache pas ce que
c'est un produit qui était très demandé
il faut beaucoup communiquer pour que
les chefs d'entreprise sache bien qu'il
est disponible
le refinancement du cic eux c'est pareil
oseo est prêt dès que l'instruction
fiscale du ministère des finances sera
publié nous pouvons commencer à
refinancer le cic de nos clients tpe
tout est en place les chaînes
informatiques sont en place le réseau
régional d'oséo efforts mais il n'y a
plus qu'à obtenir cette instruction
fiscale qui permettra très aisément et
sans conditionnalité excessive de céder
les créances fiscales sont deux exemples
d'un mode de fonctionnement de osez
aujourd'hui qui se projette dans bpi
financement doit être le contenu de
cette instruction fiscale mais le
contenu est précisément lié à
l'ensemble des dispositions qui
permettent la cession de créances
fiscales
alors donc on l'attend je pense pour la
semaine prochaine ou au courant au plus
tard la première semaine du mois de
février
ça produit qui est très attendu et qui
représentera pour pour bpi financement
oséo donc environ 2 milliards d'euros de
flux sur l'exercice 2013 et 2 milliard
d'euros sur les 2 milliards d'euros
il y en aura environ la moitié pour des
pme té i et l'autre moitié pour des tpe
auquel la prestation sera proposé sous
la forme d'un fonds de garantie 2
milliards d'euros sur un total de 10
milliards d'euros pour l'ensemble des
pme françaises 20 milliards d'euros pour
l'économie française la moitié pour les
entreprises l'autre moitié pour les pme
et dans les 10 milliards des pme 2
milliards pour pour oséo donc
l'investissement comme très significatif
voila voila on t'aime liminaire ce que
je peux dire merci monsieur le fret lié
aux acteurs jeu je me tourne le feph le
rapporteur général
oui merci ce président là l'heure qu'il
est nous allons être bref les uns et les
autres
je fais partie ici avec je crois
beaucoup de collègues sénateurs de ceux
qui ont estimé que la création de cette
bpi était une excellente initiative et
je m'aperçois en vous écoutant monsieur
dufour que vous avez déjà pris à bras le
corps ce dossier et que les ambitions
que nous avons pour la réussite de ce
projet vous
les mettez clairement en avant et vous
les partager en annonçant d'ores et déjà
vouloir accélérer les choses le plus
possible et faire en sorte que oseo soit
partie prenante dans la réussite des
attentes des besoins et des ambitions
qui sont clairement manifesté
aujourd'hui au plus haut niveau en
france donc je ne peux que vous donner
acte de cet engagement clairement
manifesté pour la réussite de ce projet
je vais néanmoins me permets de vous
poser deux ou trois questions très
simples la première en ce qui concerne
la gouvernance de cet ensemble qui
regroupe donc différentes entités en
particulier deux lunes donc qui est une
unité prêteuses et l'autre qui est une
unité j'allais dire investisseuse ne
craignez-vous pas en étant responsable
de l'ensemble est donc implicitement pdg
de l'une et de l'autre composante voir
apparaître
dans les temps à venir quelques risques
de conflits d'intérêts entre ses deux
unités qui ont des vocations certes un
peu parallèle mais qui peuvent parfois
sur le terrain se trouvaient parfois ans
dans des sujets de contradictions donc
comment vous voyez où à l'avenir est ce
une situation durable que d'envisager
les choses sous cet angle avec une
gouvernance clairement unifiée pour pour
l'avenir et quelle place
envisagez vous de réserver aux
responsables qui était à la tête de ces
entités
même si c'est pas de vous uniquement que
cela dépend mais peut être pourrions
nous informer sur les évolutions de
carrière qui sont envisageables pour ces
responsables qui ont fait du bon travail
vous l'avez dit vous-même france ou
directeur d'oséo on connais ici qu'on a
reçues de montre de nombreuses fois
commission des finances du sénat
monsieur droit voilà donc c'est un un
premier point de d'éclairage nous
apporter deuxièmement ce qui concerne
les fonds
donc va avoir besoin bpi pour
fonctionner ce que vous envisagez
d'accélérer la libération des capitaux
propres qui ont été souscrits et qui
restent à verser à oséo 500 millions et
au fait s'il y en a bien plus 3
milliards 6 parce que là c'est une une
question qui évidemment à porte sur les
questions de deux budgétaire et dès lors
il n'est pas inintéressant d'avoir un
point d'éclairage à ce sujet
et puis enfin s'agissant des régions une
question qu'on peut se poser c'est de
savoir si au fond il y aura un modèle
unique pour le fonctionnement de la bpi
dans les régions ou bien s'il y aura un
fonctionnement à la carte au front ce
une question qu'on on peut là aussi se
poser parce qu'on a bien senti qu'au
niveau des prix en région il y avait le
la volonté d'exister d'une façon
significative au travers des comités
régionaux d'orientation et dès lors en
terme donc de fonctionnement dans le
temps comment cette marge d'autonomie
qui semble-t-il est souhaitée par les
priant de région va pouvoir être prises
en considération et ce qui rend une
forme de fonctionnement à la carte par
monsieur le président quelques questions
simples pour compléter les informations
qu'on a déjà obtenu
merci beaucoup cela compensera je me
permettrait d'y ajouter une question
technique sur le modèle prudentielles
est ce que vous pouvez
monsieur dufour nous confirmer que deux
modèles prudentielles coexisteront bien
au sein de ce groupe
le modèle de droit commun le modèle de
balle pour la filiale de crédit et
d'autre part le modèle caisse des dépôts
et qui est sans doute plus tôt plus
contraignant pour les uns pour les
interventions en fonds propres j'ai
compris qu'il y aurait coexistence de
ces deux modèles prudentielles est ce
bien le cas
ou sinon quel est le régime et le modèle
prudentielles selon lequel fonctionnera
bpi group
très bien vu répondre à ces quatre
questions sur la question du conflit
d'intérêts évidemment une question
fondamentale
je vais la traiter de ce sous plusieurs
angles
pourquoi parce que au fond le coeur du
sujet il est dans les régions plus que
nous avons des délégations régionales
d'oseo qui accorde des crédits d avance
innovations des prêts à taux zéro des
avances remboursables 90% des décisions
sont prises en régions 90% des décisions
de crédit et l'innovation sont prises en
région nous allons développer l'activité
fonds propres en région aujourd'hui
c'est reprenant à peu près 36 est chargé
d'investissements professionnels de
l'investissement
certaines régions ont 80 personnes
d'autres une seulement nous allons
doubler cette taille pour aller
progressivement vers une structure qui
représentera au total en france une
centaine de personnes dans les
directions régionales de la bpi il y
aura donc des professions du crédit et
des professionnels des fonds propres des
professionnels des fonds propres de la
direction régionale ne reporteront pas
structurellement au directeur régional
de labé pays mais seulement
fonctionnellement pour la gestion des
ressources humaines le partage
d'expérience et sait en revanche leur
chaîne de commandement
et de reporting opérationnel sera
l'activité fonds propres de l'abbaye
autrement dit ils seront rattachés à des
délégations inter régionale des fonds
propres à six qui elles mêmes seront
rattachés à la structure fonds propres
de la bpi qui s'appellera probablement
bpi france investissement ils seront
tous ces responsables de fonds propres
en région salariés n'ont pas de la de
l'entité légale
oseo mais de l'entité légale société de
gestion fonds propres des pays france
investissement
cette société de gestion elle sera une
société de gestion agréée par la mf
gérant des fonds communs de placement à
risque et donc vous aurez dans une
direction régionale d'oséo à la fois des
banquiers salariés d'oseo statut oseo et
des investisseurs salarié d'une société
de gestion à mf statut par parenthèse
d'ailleurs caisse des dépôts et
consignations je ne suis pas lancer dans
un chantier de fusion des statuts qui
paraissait pas du tout et de la priorité
du moment d'un côté on a deux mille
salariés de l'autre côté deux sens on le
fera un jour peut être mais en tout cas
c'est c'est absolument pas la priorité
et voilà et donc le directeur régional
de la bpi
il aura une vision 360 degrés ce qui se
passe dans les fonds propres de sa
région mais il ne participera pas aux
décisions d'investissement participa pas
aux décisions d'investissement au cas
particulier des fonds privés dans
lesquelles nous injectons de l'argent
dans notre activité fonds de fonds nous
finançons 90 fonds régionaux donc dans
tous vos régions et fonds régionaux sont
financés aujourd'hui par la caisse donc
de mende par la bpi
le principe est exactement leur
exactement le même qui va représenter la
bpi au conseil d'administration de ces
fonds
très simplement s'il ya une place ça
sera bpi fonds propres s'il ya deux
places ça sera belle île fonds propres
plus le directeur régional de labé pays
mais sans pouvoir de décision sur les
investissements fonds propres voilà la
philosophie et c'est là que sont les
grands flux d'investissements directs de
la bpi
puisqu'aujourd'hui ont fait 90 dossiers
en région par an et demain on va monter
à 150 mm 200 dossiers par an les
dossiers traités en national maintenant
sont en faible nombre un scellé grosso
modo 10 investissement du fsi chaque
année plus je dirais une vingtaine d'
investissements faits dans les fonds
thématiques biotechnologies et co éco
transition internet fonds de capital et
est le co investissement mots des
participations enfin voilà donc c'est un
nombre relativement limité les décisions
d'investissement pour ces fonds là sont
prises dans des comités d'investissement
de la société de gestion cdc entreprises
comme les investissements composé des
équipes d'investissement elle même plus
le cas échéant d'un ou des souscripteurs
qui sont l'état et la caisse des dépôts
et consignations et donc pour que on est
dans une gouvernance qui est totalement
déconnectée de la gouvernance bancaire
il ya des comités engagements bancaires
et comité d'engagement et de décisions
en investissements ce qui ce qui
honnêtement laisse très peu de place à
des sujets de conflit d'intérêt majeur
je dirais que les grands cons le grand
conflit d'intérêts potentiel c'est un
dossier important qui passe en comité
d'investissement du fsi d'une entreprise
dans laquelle il faut mettre 15 millions
d'euros est qui et qui passent dans le
même temps dans un comité l'engagement
de bpi france un financement dont 2 0
c'est extrêmement rare dans ce cas là on
le gérera par la part le juste le
l'abstention du dirigeant fait rire de
moi-même à chacun de ces comités
d'investissement
je prends un exemple qui et altice que
vous ne connaissez bien j'imagine altis
fait l'objet à la fois d'un crédit oseo
et d'une avance d'une injection de fonds
propres du fsi plus des obligations
convertibles montré un cas comme celui
ci le directeur général de la bpi ne pas
participer aux réunions qui ne
participera pas au règne
ensuite les capitaux non libéré oui en
effet 3 6 milliards d'euros pour le fsi
est théoriquement 500 millions d'euros
pour oséo banque les 3,6 milliards
d'euros du fsi ce que nous recommandons
c'est que 1,6 milliard d'euros soit
versée à la fin d'année 2013 pour
assurer la trésorerie du fsi en 2014
ensuite se pose la question des deux
autres milliards
ces deux autres milliards ne sont sont
juridiquement libérable avant septembre
octobre 2014
c'est à dire cinq ans après la création
du fsi la situation de fait bon est ce
que l'état et la caisse des prêts
anciens sont voudront libérer ce capital
avant septembre 2014
ou bien est-ce qu'on devra trouver un
une méthode permettant de reporter
quelques années la libération de ce
capital c'est à voir c'est à discuter
avec nos actionnaires
ce qui est certain c'est que si nous
obtenons les 1,6 milliard de la fin 2013
nous avons de quoi fonctionner pendant
les années 2014 2015
il n'y a pas d'urgence absolue à avoir
les 2 autres milliards avec c'est avec
cet argent là nous avons aujourd'hui la
possibilité d'investir deux milliards
d'euros par an 2 milliards d'euros par
an en fonds propres des pme françaises d
un trou et le français sait déjà c'est
déjà considérable
alors le modèle pour oséo maintenant 500
millions d'euros d'augmentation de
capital
500 millions d'euros je pense qu'il est
clair maintenant que nous les aurons pas
et que sur les 500 millions d'euros nous
aurons seulement 100 millions d'euros et
les autres 400 millions d'euros sont
réinjectées au travers du programme
investissements d'avenir en une
initiative du pays à deux fonds de fonds
thématiques donc réinjecter plutôt que
d'être en paix pays financement ils
seront en bpi investissements et
s'ajouteront donc aux ressources dont on
parlait à l'instant de capital non
libéré du fsi on parle de 690 millions
d'euros que le conseil général de
l'industrie pays et à l'intention de
nous confier en gestion pour une
activité supplémentaire de fonds de
fonds allant vers des fonds privés qui
sont eux-mêmes spécialisés sur des
thèmes d'investissement sectoriel ou ouf
lierse est effectivement temps cdc
entreprises aujourd'hui demain dans des
pays financement mais bp fonds propres
alors est-ce que c'est grave ne pas
avoir les 500 millions d'euros d'oséo
c'est pas très grave puisque j'ai
aujourd'hui oseo a franchement les
moyens avec six fonds propres donc le
budget de l'état pour les garder en le
plan s'ils sont réaffectés sacrament ces
sommes-là sont réaffectés en fonte
filière d'accord c'était c'était des
sommes qui venait du pays a et donc dans
le cas des arbitrages que le prémunit
sera annoncée lundi dernier ces
sommes-là ont été déplacées elles
restent en fait à la bpi humaine passe
de financement en fonds propres
c'est bien noté merci beaucoup
alors les régions les régions
est ce qu'il y aura un modèle unique de
bpi en région alors la réponse est oui
il y aura un modèle unique de bpi en
région en revanche est ce qu'il y aura
un modèle unique de relations entre bpi
région et les conseils régionaux la
réponse est non on s'adapte à chacune
des régions à leurs souhaits à
l'existant qui est en général
extrêmement riche dans la plupart des
régions
on n'a en effet pas attendu la création
de bpi pour créer des fonds commun de
garantie des fonds communs d'innovation
ou des mous des cofinancements sur des
initiatives de crédit sans parler des
fonds d'investissement qui sont déjà
financés par la caisse
donc on va sabine on va encore une fois
faire le diagnostic précis de ce qui
existe dans chacune des régions et voir
dans quelle mesure dans une logique
d'amélioration continue on peut faire
plus et mieux plus et mieux ça veut dire
certainement plus de moyens dans tel ou
tel cas j'étais lundi avec le prénom le
conseil régional de lorraine et je lui
ai dit on pourrait tout à fait en
lorraine faire un prêt pour l'innovation
c'est finalement peu d'argent mobilisé
il suffirait de cinq cent mille euros
pour la région lorraine pour permettre à
bp y de lancer le prêt pour l'innovation
en lorraine
voilà une idée donc on peut faire la
même chose pour le prêt vert par exemple
ou pour le prêt pour l'export il ya des
régions qui veulent mettre les bouchées
doubles sur l'export dans ces
discussions qui ont commencé avec des
programmes d'action et qui vont être
mises en place et qui seront suivies
dans mon équipe par une personne à plein
temps qui sera chargé de suivre le 22
plans régionaux d'assurer le reporting
de ses plans au profit des régions
et puis de vérifier que les bonnes idées
du nord de la france sont appliquées au
sud et inversement
alors on joue il y aura un modèle
régional de bpi qui sera standard avec
un directeur adjoint de la bpi qui aura
trois délégués à déléguer fonds propres
allez
financement et un délégué innovation et
comme je vous disais tout à l'heure le
délégué fonds propres lui rapportant en
pointillés et raconte en direct à la
structure nationale de la bpi modèle
prudentielles le président hu y prendre
du mur et dans celle de la caisse sur la
partie fonds propres et bâle iii sur la
partie bancaire
est-ce que ça pose un problème à la bpi
réponse est non le problème que ça
aurait pu poser et qui inquiétait
beaucoup l'état actionnaire à 50%
c'était est ce que le modèle prudentiel
de la caisse peut le cas échéant
empêcher le développement de la force de
frappe bancaire de l'abbaye
nous avons fait tous les calculs et j'ai
posé une seule question qui était la
suivante est ce que en respectant le
vaudais prudentiel de la caisse dépôts
et consignations on peut si nécessaire
d'ailleurs
et aujourd'hui ça n'est pas encore
mobilisé 10 milliards d'euros de crédits
de plus en force de frappe chez oséo en
plus des 30 d'aujourd'hui la réponse est
oui
donc si on veut enlever rançon n'est pas
30 on est à 25
on va passer à 30 par capitalisation et
profits si les failles de marché
bancaire était telle qu'il fallait
réellement intervenir dans ces
proportions là peut-on monter de 30 à 40
milliards d'euros réponse est oui en
respectant le ratio tier one de la
caisse qui est de 65%
ceci a permis de dédramatiser
complètement la question donc nous
avançons de cette manière là maintenant
si dans les années qui viennent
il s'avère pas que parce que on a donné
à la bpi des tâches supplémentaires des
fonctions supplémentaires
le fameux
modèle financier de la caisse commence à
poser question
et bien les deux actionnaires se
réuniront pour en discuter ce sera une
clause de revoyure
mais on peut parfaitement démarré avec
merci beaucoup de ces réponses alors je
suppose qu'un certain nombre de
collègues souhaite vous interroger donc
alors j'ai noté des demandes
d'intégration de sa batterie elle-même
keller de monsieur éric bocquet de
monsieur thierry foucaud d'un marie
hélène des esgaulx le monsieur patriat
j'avais noté le premier messieurs michel
berson et à ma droite personne à ma
droite
pour l'instant je parle de l'adjointe
géographique n'est ce pas alors monsieur
monsieur le préfigurateur veiller en
cendres la question de monsieur françois
patriat président de la région
merci monsieur le président il faut que
moi je voudrais ici saluer la grande
volonté dialogue dont vous avez fait
preuve au cours de ces dernières
semaines
rencontrés sur le terrain tous les
acteurs les élus beaucoup et moi j'ai eu
plaisir de pouvoir vous rencontrer pour
évoquer la vision que pouvait avoir
chaque président territoriaux vous
n'avez pas vu des présents de région au
début beaucoup de personnes et puis vous
avez déjà répondu à beaucoup de
questions et françois marc a posé la
question essentielle
donc je vais pas vous la reposer
d'autant plus que je suis pas dans cette
position
l'hégémonie régionale où les régions
voudrait aujourd'hui si elles sont déjà
parties prenantes et vous l'avez dit
s'ils vont déjà beaucoup créé de fonds
spécifiques ou moi je pense que la dti
12e son rôle pleinement à côté des
régions en associant nos outils et le
schéma de mise en réseau qu'on nous
proposait pour la bourgogne vous a
repris par ailleurs mme de paraître le
chemin il correspond au territoire
je comprends bien que d'autres régions
ont d'autres je n'ai parlé aussi avec
jean pierre masseret ces jours derniers
jours leur m donc ce que vous proposez
aujourd'hui comme dialogue en dix ans il
y aura une structure en région qui sera
unique qui travaillera avec les régions
le guichet unique n'est pas forcément la
bonne la bonne
la bonne réponse ne satisfait mais
satisfait donc on aura le plaisir cette
annonce et le 21 février dit jean marc
première réunion j'en suis très honoré
je pense que beaucoup d'autres illustres
ont associé nous en parlons aussi même
si les régions ont le rôle de chef de
file économique avec les structures
infra territoriales et qui sont prêtes
tel même participant aussi à d'autres
financements associés théâtre démarche
coopérative donc c'est pas une question
mais puisque vous avez répondu déjà
françois marque c'est un assentiment
une petite question subsidiaire
simplement dans les rôles de la de la
dpi la transition énergétique fait
partie de ces missions il a été demandé
par le chef de l'état
c'est la création de beaucoup d'emplois
délocalisables nous avons créé par
exemple un cluster éolien en bourgogne
que nous souhaitons que soit ton
compagne et là on fait un peu moins que
photovoltech et dans l'est aussi dans
tout ce qui est bio masse et autres
sk ce vieux l'identique de ce qui se
fait aujourd'hui à la fois en
grande-bretagne royaume uni et en
allemagne où il ya des bancs publics
spécifiques et ressemble un peu à l'est
des pays qui font des prêts automatique
dans ce genre d'investissement je pense
à k effet kfw ou à green abaissement est
ce que la bpi entend s'inspirer de ces
exemples pour ce domaine particulier qui
va conditionner pas mal de création
d'emplois merci c'est un françois
patriat la parole fabien oui merci
beaucoup monsieur dufour que trois 3
questions
j'avais compris que le financement de
l'isolation de 500 mille logements qui
était un programme présidentiel devait
transiter par les dépits comment ça
marche
deuxième question oseo peut-être bien le
fsi était bénéficiaire de gros montant
du grand emprunt pour être capitalisés
avoir des moyens supplémentaires est ce
que tout ça se poursuit et enfin est-ce
que vous pouvez nous dire quelques mots
sur le subtil équilibre entre respect
des trois structures oseo fsi cdc
entreprises et la nécessaire fusion
synergie dans la bpi enfin comment vous
concevez 7
oui d'ailleurs sur ce point enfin
écouter grand intérêt vos réponses mais
j'ai posé la même question dans mon
introduction enfin je n'ai pas entendu
de 2,2 de réponse enfin je peux être été
inattentif mais enfin je crois qu'il est
très utile que l'on revienne sur cette
sorte de philosophie nous faudra nous
présenter juxtaposition culture
d'entreprise comment est-ce qu'on passe
d'un schéma à l'autre est la parole et à
éric bocquet bien merci monsieur le
président russe du four nous avions
évidemment en tant que groupe salué
l'initiative de la création de 7 des
pays nous l'avions d'ailleurs soutenu et
expliquer pourquoi nous avions soutenu
mais nous avons toujours une certaine
réserve régulièrement quant aux
nominations de proprement dit
donc n'en prenaient pas ombrage monsieur
dufour surtout failli s'agit pas de
votre personne mais d'une manière
générale nous avons beaucoup de réserves
sur les nominations
quelle qu'elle soit quelques organismes
qu'elle concerne donc nous nous
abstiendrons sur le moment du vote en
question mais sur le fond j'aurai
quelques questions très concrètes et
courtes à vous poser sur quelles
qualités respectives de ces la cdc
d'oseo et du fsi allez vous pouvoir vous
appuyez de l'expérience accumulée par
ces organismes en matière
d'investissements publics comment
allez-vous utiliser les atouts dont on a
pu découvrir l'existence dans les trois
organismes en question
ensuite quelles sont à vos yeux les
objectifs prioritaires en terme
d'intervention de l'ebbe pays quelles
sont les urgences dans les mois qui
viennent à vos yeux qui apparaissent et
troisième question en matière
d'organisation de quels moyens humains
allez vous disposez et la question
suivante vous l'avez abordé dans votre
intervention préalablement mais je
m'interroge sur l'articulation que vous
allez mettre en place avec les
territoires et les élus et y compris
peut-être les représentants du personnel
des entreprises concernées par exemple
vous avez dit et c'est légitime vouloir
vous adapter à la réalité des régions il
ya des spécificités les territoires
économiques ne sont pas du tout les
mêmes
mais comment allez-vous articulé dans ce
conte à votre intervention avec la
vision des élus et leurs représentants
les territoires concernés merci à eric
bocquet la parole et au président
thierry foucaud oui merci monsieur le
président merci
s'ils ne font qu'un bon personne ici et
n'est sans savoir que les entreprises
publiques locales dont le mouvement
d'ailleurs est en forte croissance
constitue pour les territoires des
leviers efficaces et en même temps
réactif en matière de développement
économique et bien sûr sondés de ses
donneurs d'ordres majeur pour les
paiements
on sait bien que les op elles sont
éligibles aux activités de la baby dont
l'action bien sûr comme vous l'avez
rappelé est orientée sur les petites et
moyennes entreprises mais ceci sans
référence au droit communautaire et que
dans les faits seuls certains produits
de la bpi sont ouverts aux pl à savoir
les prêts à moyen ou long terme
alors je pense nous pensons qu'il ya un
enjeu
la 1 pour les entreprises publiques
locales à savoir ouvrir un plus grand
nombre de produits aux apl et que bien
sûr cette décision relève de la doctrine
d'intervention de la baby à partir de là
j'ai deux caisses de questions monsieur
dufourcq
quelle sera la doctrine d'intervention
de la bpi vis-à-vis des ep hell et une
deuxième question à partir du fait que
certains prêts limitée aujourd'hui aux
pme au sens bien sûr du droit
communautaire
pourrait-il être ouvert au cem et au sp
n
je vous remercie merci beaucoup à
thierry foucaud la parole et à marie
hélène des esgaulx
merci monsieur le président monsieur du
fond moi j'aime beaucoup votre parcours
de celui de chef d'entreprise avant de
devenir banquier
voilà la question elle est quel est
votre point de vu l'enchaînement le lien
qui pourrait avoir qui pourrait avoir
lieu entre la bpi et la coface
c'est à marie-hélène des esgaulx la
parole enfin dernier intervenant
inscrits jusqu'ici un michel berson
merci monsieur le président monsieur
dufour que je voudrais savoir quelles
sont les orientations que vous entendez
donné à la bpi pour optimaliser le
crédit d'impôt recherche qui comme
chacun sait est au service de de
l'innovation de la compétitivité
il semblerait qu'il y ait un un obstacle
pour le préfinancement des crêtes du
crédit d'impôt recherche pour les tpe
pme et les i et dans la mesure où on
assimilerait pas le remboursement
anticipé donc du crédit d'impôt
recherche remboursement de la tva de
similitudes entre les deux vous nous
avez annoncé que vous allez refinancer
le crédit d'impôt compétitivité emploi
est ce que vous avez comme objectif est
bien d'optimaliser lusage du crédit
d'impôt recherche
pourquoi michel berson il n'y a pas
d'autres pas d'autres demandes de parole
et j'aurais voulu ajouter une dernière
question de caractère technique et
monsieur le préfet curateur au cours du
débat parlementaire et d'ailleurs vous
avez fait allusion dans votre précédent
propos et il a été évoqué la possibilité
de transférer des actifs d'une filiale à
l'autre du groupe en fonction des
besoins
au vu des masses ceci permet de penser
que ce transfert pourrait concerner et
des actifs actuellement dans le fsi est
susceptible d'être transféré vers oseo
et si de tels transferts d'actifs
étaient envisagés il pourrait du point
de vue des finances publiques poser
question on peut notamment se demander
si l'état actionnaire ne pourrait pas
être tenté d'alléger par ce biais des
charges incombant à l'état financeurs et
qui subventionne aujourd'hui le soutien
à l'innovation ou les garanties de zéro
et il est donc important de savoir
quelles règles encadreront la
circulation des fonds la circulation des
actifs entre les activités de
financement et d'investissement de la
bpi et car bien sûr nous devons veiller
à ce qu'il n'y ait pas débudgétisation
bon suite à des fins de clarification
que je vous pose cette question
au demeurant ce que vous nous avez dit
tout à l'heure sur le capital m'ont
appelé montre qu'il ya au contraire
fuite hors budget isation que
débudgétisation si j'ai bien compris
voilà donc à vous de bien vouloir
répondre aux différentes questions après
quoi nous aurons la redoutable tâche de
devoir nous prononcer par un vote
merci monsieur le président alors dans
l'or sur la transition énergétique
merci sur la transition énergétique oseo
est extrêmement présents sont d'ailleurs
communiquer beaucoup mais je vous donne
quelques chiffres très rapidement
attendre et de l'innovation oseo
consacrent 20 % de ses budgets
d'intervention on allait l'innovation à
des projets qui sont liées au
développement durable et la transition
écologique
un monsieur patriat 20% de l'oseo
innovation c'est déjà la transition
écologique dans la partie crédit crédit
bail prêts à long terme prêts à moyen
terme
c'est une masse de 500 millions d'euros
qui est prêtée chaque année en
l'occurrence en 2012 à la transition
énergétique c'est-à-dire 15 % du total
des co financement d'oseo en 2012 donc
c'est déjà significatif il faut que vous
sachiez qu'oseo est un acteur majeur de
l'éolien et du photovoltaïque en france
absolument majeur le sol le seul
sous secteur dans lequel oseo est absent
c'est l'éolien offshore
mais pour le reste en particulier chez
oséo bretagne mais pas seulement
il ya énormément de dossiers qui sont
des dossiers de transition écologique on
va continuer et puis et puis au
catalogue dosés ou vous avez un prêt
vert vous avez un prêt écoénergie enfin
il ya toute une gamme de produits qui va
qui va être développé alors le
financement d'isolation de 500 mille
logements
madame la sénatrice je ne sais pas
répond à la question je suis désolé je
vous reviendrai
alors la question sur le pays h et oséo
le pays et intervient dans oseo à double
titre
1 il est la preuve la promesse
d'augmentation de capital dont j'ai
parlé qui a été revue à la baisse et
transférés vers les fonds propres et 2
le pays a ainsi que le f lui
bref tous les fonds du ministère de
l'industrie donne ton en gestion à oseo
innovation des volumes de subventions à
distribuer qui sont des volumes très
importants
oseo innovation pour l' avance
remboursable et le prêt à taux zéro
c'est chaque année une dotation
budgétaire de l'ordre de 200 à 250
millions d'euros
vous devez rajoutez à ça environ 300
millions d'euros de subventions qui sont
gérés par oseo pour le compte du
ministère de l'industrie
aimer c'est les subventions qui sont
fondées sur un principe différent qui
est celui d'un appel d'offres thématique
appelle la proposition jury décision
instruction du dossier est ensuite suivi
du projet dans la durée
voilà ce que font les équipes d'oseo
innovation en région alors ensuite
culture d'entreprise synergies et c'est
pour ça c'est très précisément la raison
pour laquelle depuis le début en
examinant le sujet je me suis dit que
une gouvernance dans laquelle il y
aurait un directeur général qui aurait
simplement de collaborateurs qui serait
un patron de la banque un patron des
fonds propres n'avait aucune chance de
produire une entreprise aucune
donc donc j'aurai un comité de direction
avec et six patrons békés qui vont
travailler ensemble
vous ne serez pas surpris que dans la
tente de toutes les confirmations de ma
candidature et cetera j'ai quand même
organisé des transversalités des
contacts entre ces populations qui ne se
parlaient pas donc nous avons fait des
réunions communes des séminaires commun
et les gens se sont progressivement
découvert avec énormément d'intérêt pour
une raison très simple qui est que les
abris zataz les mêmes clients donc comme
d'habitude dans le monde de l'entreprise
et on est dans le monde de l'entreprise
quand vous rassembler des entités qui ne
se parlaient pas mais qui ont les mêmes
clients
eh bien vous avez un rayonnement
d'énergie d'initiatives dont on pourrait
faire si c'est fantastique ce que vous
faites donc la bpi va rayonner pour
cette simple raison là j'ai pas besoin
d'imposer des synergies les gens ont
envie de travailler ensemble
alors il ya une dimension de
l'organisation de la bpi qui va nous
permettre d'accélérer cet effet enfin
une fois synergétique c'est la direction
de l'innovation
il y a aujourd'hui oseo innovation et de
l'autre côté des fonds d'investissement
dans les biotechnologies la transition
écologique et l'internet ces gens là se
parlaient pas et donc le continuum de
l'innovation n'était pas assurée je
proposerai de mettre l'ensemble de ces
entités dans une seule direction sous
une seule autorité
aucune personne aura la responsabilité
du continuum de l'innovation alors sur
quelle quelle qualité respectifs et à
tous appuyé moi j'allais dire tout
simplement à la fois l'extrême
professionnalisme des équipes et la
culture d'entreprise la culture
d'entreprise d'oseo elle est une culture
pme c'est une culture de rapidité de
délais courts c'est une culture de
francis dans l'expression les gens sont
extrêmement cash
comme des patrons de pme et c'est une
culture très entrepreneuriale moyenne
d'âge de veau et aux faibles je suis
encore impressionné par la visite que
j'ai eus lundi chez oséo en lorraine et
à nancy
il n'y a que les jeunes et quand je dis
des jeunes c'est des jeunes de moins de
30 ans c'est donc c'est une entreprise
qui est très dynamique très jeune et
très entrepreneuriale si vous prenez cdc
entreprises cdc entreprises au fond
c'est la même chose puisque cdc
entreprises a doublé de taille depuis
2011 donc énormément de recrutement de
jeunes et vous prenez le fsi le fsi est
une est une start up
il a été créé en 2011 énormément de
jeunes aussi et donc autant l'impression
mental qu'on peut avoir d'une banque
publique d'investissement installée
pourrait laisser penser que c'est une
structure qui va falloir déplacer
la vérité c'est que c'est un chevau
légers c'est à chevaux légers c'est une
très belle corvette qui naturellement on
va avancer assez vite
objectif prioritaire urgences on n'a pas
que les compétitivité donc l'urgence
absolue c'est la trésorerie des pme et
donc la facilité de trésorerie le
préfinancement du cic e et toutes les
actions qui sont menées par paolo
deuxième urgence augmenter la puissance
de feu d'investissement fonds propres en
région donc une initiative que je
propose de prendre et que je confirmerai
si ma candidature est adopté c'est de
doubler les effectifs des faits six
régions et les fonds gérés par fsi
région donc de passer de 300 à grosso
modo 600 voire 700 millions d'euros et
de 45 professionnels à 90 voire 100
professionnels donc une montée en
puissance très importante des faits six
réunions moi ça ce sont les trois
urgences qui nous occupe et vous pouvez
rajouter des sujets qui sont
fondamentaux comme en particulier la
titrisation de crédit de pme de manière
à ce que l'assurance vie française
puisse acheter du crédit des pme de
qualité
ou bien le marché obligataire des pme
autre urgence l'export je suis frappé de
voir que abord très très sincèrement et
en transparence jeu je découvre le drame
de l'export dans lequel nous sommes tous
ayant travaillé pendant 10 ans chez cap
gemini constamment à l'international je
ne m'en étais pas rendu compte
parce qu'une entreprise qui se développe
à l'international se développent et j'ai
dit je n'avais pas conscience des 81
milliard d'euros or les 80 milliards
d'euros pour les combler il n'y a pas
d'autre solution que d'avoir un
changement d'attitude et d'énergie
investi dans le monde des pme françaises
l'automobile ne remontera pas et
l'énergie elle est ce qu'elle est donc
le plan export des aînés des pme
françaises est un sujet qui me paraît
absolument majeur qu'est ce que la bpi
peut faire plusieurs choses
elle est le grand réseau de distribution
de toutes les aides publiques potentiels
aux pme françaises c'est le réseau le
plus capillaires et c'est le réseau le
plus entrepreneuriale le moins
administratif si je puis dire le moins
bureaucratique le plus rapide le plus
efficace c'est demain c'est donc un
actif fantastique je recommanderais
fortement que la bpi via oséo distribuer
l'assurance prospection de la coface par
exemple nous avons déjà décidé que
ubifrance logerait dans les directions
en juin de 0 40 responsables d'ubifrance
de manière à ce qu'ils soient connectés
au réseau de distribution d'oseo qui est
pas un guichet un qui est un réseau pro
actif où chaque chargé d'affaires de
oséo va voir 100 entreprises par an avec
sa voiture
ce sont des sujets qui se traite dans la
cuisine des pme c'est ce que fait oseo
donc il faudra être à ma recommandation
de plus en plus utilisé des pays
financement oséo pour placer toute la
gamme de produits dead à l'export
de la puissance publique aujourd'hui je
trouve c'est très insuffisant on peut
faire beaucoup beaucoup plus les moyens
humains j'en ai parlé
l'organisation en ai parlé
l'articulation avec les élus bon elle
est faite de l'effet d'un dialogue
constant 1 à tous les niveaux national
et régional les comités d'orientation
régionaux le comité national
d'orientation et elle est faite d'une
philosophique et une philosophie de
haute couture c'est à dire qu'encore une
fois on fera 22 plan différent et je
dirais c'est le message que je livre
présente conseillers régionaux plus on
n'en fera plus on sera content je pense
qu'on peut dans l'export faire beaucoup
plus on peut dans l'innovation faire
beaucoup plus on peut dans les crédits
mais à nina moyen terme faire plus et le
message que je donne aux opéras conseils
régionaux c'est on peut faire beaucoup
plus dans le crédit il n'est pas
forcément nécessaire de faire beaucoup
plus dans les dents dans les fonds
propres c'est déjà beaucoup d'argent
dans les fonds propres
on va en remettre en revanche pour faire
du bon crédit moyen terme bonifié pas
cher sans prise de garantie sur le
patrimoine de l'entrepreneur faut de
l'argent
le prêt pour l'innovation du président
de la république annoncé à oseo
excellence
on ne peut pas lancer parce qu'on n'a
pas l'argent donc si les régions veulent
contribuer c'est plutôt vers cette dans
cette direction là que je proposerai que
qu'elles investissent à nos côtés près
pour le près pôle innovation il est
fantastique c'est après à 7 ans 100%
garanti 100% garanti parce que le taux
de sinistralité sa inévitablement élevé
pas de prise de garantie sur le
patrimoine de l'entrepreneur bon très
belle idée
on peut pas l'annoncer ce qui m'amène à
votre question sur la circulation du
capital et des fonds propres à
l'intérieur la bpi
bon il ya une circulation du capital qui
est absolument indispensable
c'est celle qui permet d'augmenter le
capital d'oseo pour que oseo puisse
faire plus de crédit celle ci elle
passera par le dividende des fonds
propres est une décision souveraine du
conseil d'administration
d'affecter ce dividende à une
augmentation de capital de la filiale
bancaire la gouvernance est là pour
protéger la caisse des dépôts et
consignations puisque si la caisse
refuse que le dividende soit affecté une
augmentation de capital de la banque
eh bien ça ne se fera pas tout l'état ne
peut pas faire défaut en la matière à
ses obligations
ça vaut également pour les aides à
l'innovation
aujourd'hui où la garantie aujourd'hui
l'état verse donc dans le budget 2013
215 millions d'euros pour l'innovation
100 millions d'euros pour la garantie 50
millions d'euros pour la trésorerie plus
des chouïa qui sont 20 millions par ci
20 millions par là pour faire des
crédits mais annie je vois très peu de
risques de débugage et isation sur
l'innovation la ligne existe elle est
extrêmement stable
elle est tenue et
et oseo n'a pas eu à se battre année
après année pour qu'elle soit maintenue
en revanche le voit un risque sur la
gare on savait qu'elle est la
programmation des finances publiques de
veau et docks temps les trois ans dans
le pm t il est prévu de 115 millions
d'euros par an en revanche je vois un
risque sur la garantie
je les fonds de garantie pour
fonctionner doivent être abondé il avait
été massivement abondé en 2009 900
millions d'euros
ça a permis de tenir jusqu'à 2012
j'ai obtenu présent de république qu'il
soit abondé de 100 millions d'euros en
2013 par prélèvement exceptionnel sur le
pays à ce qui nous permet de tenir 2013
la question se posera sur 2015-2016 de
savoir comment on répond les fonds
garantis
la bonne nouvelle c'est que ces
garanties sont accordés sur des crédits
qui sont finalement pas de mauvaise
qualité donc la sinistralité
pratiquement toujours plus faible que
prévu on vit là dessus il est normal que
la caisse des dépôts et consignations se
pose
enfin exprime l'inquiétude qui est en
2015 si on a pas 100 millions d'euros
pour la garantie est ce qu'on va nous
demander de pompey 100 millions d'euros
sur les dividendes des fonds propres
pour aller alimenter des fonds de
garantie de la banque
eh ben ça sera la décision du conseil de
migration la bpi si la caisse veut pas
ça sera pas 50% du capital et une très
forte présence dans la gouvernance 50%
la gouvernance 1 donc bon c'est pas
d'inquiétude à avoir de ce point de vue
là d'une manière générale vous verrez
que mon propos est toujours de 2 de dire
qu'il n'ya pas vraiment d'inquiétude à
avoir
plus que tout et tout et quand même
construit et verrouillé et pour que
cette entreprise fonctionne vraiment
vraiment bien alors l'entreprise
publique locale sm je n'ai pas réponse à
la question je ne connais pas du tout le
sujet je ne connais pas du tout le sujet
monsieur sénateurs donc je vous
reviendrai c'est pas répondre aux
questions sur le cir arnaud kodo qui est
ici qui est directeur financier d'oseo
et que je proposerai de nommer comme
directeur financier de la bpi me fais
donc une petite fiche parce que je
n'avais pas la réponse même à la
question qui dit on préfinance déjà ça
c'est ce que j'avais en tête et on va
ouvrir une garantie en 2013 car la
créance n'est sécurisé qu'en dépenses
validée elle reste correspond certes et
compensant une fois
à présent tarif b bat parce que
pardonnez moi tout le monde n'a
peut-être pas très bien entendu parce
que le directeur financier s'est exprimé
sans micro et est ce que vous pourriez
nous redire
et comment les choses vont fonctionner
le 1 des fonds garantis 2 0 va être
ouvert aux à l'objet de crédit prêt
financement du crédit d'impôt recherche
lequel préfinancement un crédit d'impôt
recherche n'est pas complètement ses
clauses et parce que la nature de la
créance fiscale on est connu qu'une fois
les dépenses effectivement réalisés et
contrôlée d'une part et que d'autre part
la créance et compensable avec
éventuellement d'autres créances
fiscales ou d'autres recettes fiscales
donc c'est un vrai difficile à
préfinancer pour les banques et pour
cette raison doit ouvrir un fonds de
garantie à étendre la surface du fonds
de garantie et innovation au
préfinancement du cic du cir pour que
les banques soient plus alarmantes en
termes de prise de risques parce qu'il
faut prendre des risques aujourd'hui
pour préfinancer le cr qui est ouvert au
sein de bpi qui va être ouvert au sein
de bp c'est une extension de d'objets
d'un fonds de garantie en fait il
fallait très peu de choses donc sait
désormais qu'elle est une fée merci
beaucoup de cette précision qui est
importante que je le préfigurateur
aviez-vous terminé je crois que vous
êtes efforcé d'apporter les éléments les
plus précis possibles mais qu'est ce que
les autres à laquelle je n'avais pas
conduis plus président voilà inquiéter
société faîtière oseo
est-ce que c'est dramatique ce ne soit
pas le cas voilà voilà voilà
je ne pense pas que ce soit dramatique
du tout sinon je me serais battu
jusqu'au bout
non honnêtement on dans cette affaire le
mieux est peut-être un peu les minimes
bien le fait que l'entreprise soit
construite de manière totalement normal
et pas une byzantine fait que
investisseurs coréens japonais voyant
cette affaire de loin et rassure rien
donc nous avons vu moody's vendredi
matin excellente réunion le premier
roadshow va démarrer le 31 janvier bon
ce sera l'heure de vérité on verra quel
est le spread d'oseo sur la prochaine
émission mais mais à titre personnel je
n'ai pas d'inquiétude merci beaucoup
monsieur dufour et alors nous allons
donc passer au vote mais en votre
absence naturellement bien sûr et donc
je demande aux membres de la commission
et à eux seuls bons ainsi qu'à nos
collaborateurs de rester et à monsieur
le préfigurateur ainsi qu'aux membres de
la presse de bien vouloir nous quitter
voilà pour l'audition de nicolas
dufourcq qui n'a donc été nommé
directeur général de la bpi la banque
publique d'investissement si vous
souhaitez revoir cette audition elle est
disponible en vod sur notre site
internet publicsenat.fr
je vous retrouve cet après midi à partir
de 16h30 pour suivre la séance publique
à tout à l'heure